Ayé ! Je me suis fait pirater mon compte Facebook.
Non, je suis content parce que c'est la première que ça m'arrive.
Vous pensez peut-être que les pirates de Facebook, c'est des mecs qui ont des grosses lunettes
et qui sont des petits génies de l'informatique et tout... Hé, non non c'est pas ça...
En fait, ces mecs-là, c'est soit des amis ou des collègues qui s'emparent de ton PC pour écrire.
un petit statut un peu nul.
Euh... en général, en ta défaveur parce que si ça sert à rien...
Pirate : Aujourd'hui, je vais faire les courses avec Mamie. [rire bizarre]
Les mecs qui piratent les comptes Facebook, euh...
C'est toujours les mêmes. Alors en général, c'est des mecs qui sont pas très marrants.
Qui font pas trop de blagues et...
Tout d'un coup, ils se lâchent, tu vois ? Euh... c'est pas compliqué, en général, c'est toujours les mêmes trucs qu'ils écrivent.
Pirate : Ho là là, je suis homosexuel ! [rire bizarre]
Pirate : J'aime bien faire des fellations à des hommes car je suis homosexuel !
Oh ! J'aime beaucoup les fallus ! [rire bizarre] Yes !
Ce mec-là, il pense que ta réaction
elle va être positive, tu vois ? Genre, tu vas rire et tout.
Je suis homosexuel. Génial !
Je t'invite au Flunch, mec !
Et nous, en tant que victimes de ces pirates.
On a tout le temps la même réaction. Dis donc, je ne savais que j'avais un ami beauf.
Moi, je ne suis pas homo, mais je respecte...
Non mais les gars, il faut vraiment arrêter parce que déjà... D'un, on vous croit pas. Hein ? Enfin, j'veux dire moi...
Jamais j'irai écrire euh :
Tiens, tiens, je crois que je suis homosexuel.
Faut que j'avertisse mes amis tout de suite !
Mais, je me suis dit que les homosexuels, entre eux, ils peuvent pas faire cette blague, du coup.
Heureusement que les pirates de Facebook, avec leur humour, ils font pas un one man show. Parce que...
Bon, tout le monde a une femme dans la salle ?
Moi la mienne, sur son statut Facebook, j'ai écrit "Prout !"
Voilà, ce que je veux dire, c'est que...
Donc voilà, j'y pense depuis un moment, j'aimerais bien essayer de réunir les forces
et de créer une sorte de front anti-pirate de Facebook.
Mais, euh...
Si jamais vous pensez comme moi et que...
Vous vous sentez concerné par cette philosophie,
contactez-moi. Ah, au fait j'ai un nouveau blog, c'est :
NormanFaitDesVidéos.com
Au revoir !
Bonjour Hugo !
Bonjour les gens !